now recently we've seen higher profile
independent films from the likes of Edie
Byrnes Morgan Spurlock and the polish
brothers who have done incredibly well
by bypassing film festivals and going
right to iTunes do you feel that the
majority of independent filmmakers a lot
of the people that you teach their
classes are still placing too much value
too much emphasis on film festivals
well first two questions that you asked
in there that you can buy the first is
remember first-timers are not Ed Burns
are not Morgan Spurlock and another
person in there is Kevin Smith
that are doing this they became those
names once you become the name then they
can do whatever they want to do and go
directly to the consumer because they
have a following that's curious about
what are they doing what's the next we
in the big system Hollywood they call
those the walk-and-talk films that you
get the simple DSLR camera you get a
microphone the Alaia but they're about
three people and you walk around
Manhattan or your walk around Coney
Island walking and talking about your
first sex experience and what happened
in life there the walk-and-talk films
they're gonna be there but you first
have to become a Kevin Smith and Ed
Burns a Morgan Spurlock they first made
a couple independent low-budget feature
films the brothers McMullen the clerks
to get their name to get out there so
that will grow that will grow but the
question that you really ask me about is
what's this festival thing how necessary
are festivals
I heard totally agree with you festivals
are way overdone now we got it respond
to that properly 25 years ago I don't
think any of you watching at home film
George calm right now I'm going to give
you seven seconds come up with ten
festivals that existed twenty-five years
ago
if Sundance Toronto started there was
Toronto yeah there was
kans I imagine there was something in
New York there's probably something in
Los Angeles yeah Berlin woods around I'm
not sure about Hong Kong you're having a
hard time coming up with ten today
that's 25 years ago today there are
3,000 they're all over the place they're
all over the place now what good are
they there they're nice there's social
events there cultural events so if you
like a social cultural event to go to
for a night and have a party in the nice
function that's a nice thing however you
know why you independent filmmakers go
to film festivals you say it in three
different ways it's the same thing you
go to either sell your film be
discovered or get a distributor sell
your film be discovered or get a
distributor well who are you going to
sell your film to be discovered to get a
distributor from a distributor but wait
stop saying distributor that's a
building there's a human being at every
distribution company called the
acquisition executive they acquire
independent product one of those
paramount 20th century mind gates summit
Weinstein's Miramax they're all busy
making and marketing their own in-house
feature films but they know that there
are 50,000 of you independent film
makers spending your own money making
your dream and you're free to them so if
I was the Weinsteins I'd have one
employee called an acquisition executive
to go to the festival they called
circuit there is no circuit there is no
route it's until about hodgepodge to
find you people however the acquisition
executive it's a human being there are
three thousand five thousand festivals
around the world nobody really knows how
many how do you think of human being an
acquisition exec can go to in a year I
don't think they go to fifteen twelve is
a place they go to Sundance they go to
Cannes they go to Toronto maybe now they
go to Tribeca maybe they go to one in LA
maybe they go to one in Berlin maybe
in Italy maybe they go to one in Sydney
or Australia or Japan or Korea but it's
maybe twelve so of the three thousand
five thousand festivals if you would
like to sell your film be discovery get
a distributor only 12 to 15 main
anything please do not be one of those
people that makes a feature film and
spends five thousand go to every little
festival to then think you're going to
get an ad and put all those fake laurel
leaves around it and say you're a
multiple award-winning filmmaker and
it's going to make the consumer come we
know that doesn't work so the festival
alleged circuit of these three thousand
five thousand all over the place they're
useless they're nice social entities
however the major festivals 12 maybe 15
or 20 where the acquisition execs goes
those are important and you're probably
only going to get into one of them and a
fair chance you don't get into that one
but hopefully you get into that net one
so the festival circuit or those three
thousand almost useless but they're nice
social events the twelve fifteen twenty
major ones super important get into one
of them then you might show your film
next question let's say I have a small
film I don't have any you know
recognizable names in the film I submit
the Sundance I submit the South by
Southwest I submit to Conor I get
rejected by all of them and you know do
I do I continue to submit the smaller so
festivals what do I do with my film if I
don't get into the big film festivals
somebody has to be the main daddy here
I'm that person I'm not a politician I
won't be polite but I'll try to be
truthful and straight with individual
the old saying on the court players you
gotta know when to hold them when to
fold I truly believe that anybody that
makes a 90 hundred men in narrative and
doesn't know what they're doing but you
don't when you're doing your first one
everybody deserves an Oscar so you're
saying you made your first feature film
you tried Sunday and she tried to answer
you tried can she didn't get in we'll
move on with your life remember most
people it's very important when you're
an adult don't make a short there are
probably millions of you out there
thinking about making it short to
demonstrate your talent there are 5
million shorts made last year I don't
think three of them sold all it does it
demonstrates that you're a
twelve-year-old don't make sure it so
what your question is you actually made
a feature film you deserve an Oscar now
what I hope you did is you made it for
the price that you're going to think
about making it short if you made it for
five thousand thousand fifty South which
by the way brothers McMullen Ed Byrne
Kevin Smith clerks Morgan Spurlock
that's what they did that's what they
did they kept it at that budget and
you're saying what if they don't get
into festivals then you can go to the
movie cloud or you can go to the other
revenue streams and you'll get back some
not a guarantee some money or make a
profit but you're moving on that with
your second budget film that's it